[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts we
just got back from um Paris Fashion Week
men's Men's Fashion Week yo we're
different now man the posters are going
up
funny business I've never liked the
French I'll be honest with you
you put 70 French people in front of me
[Music]
I don't like them all the comics go on
it's [__] funny it's interesting it's
different it looks like I run a bath
house and I'm an art dealer at night so
[Music]
sounds like a bisexual mafia boss right
now
[Applause]
let's just grab everybody's dick
Paris Fashion Week ended on Sunday with
the final show stacked to the brim with
some of our favorite comedians theovan
Andrew Schultz Andrew Santino
stavrosaukus Jeff Ross Mateo Lane and
more all hit the runway to tell some
jokes and model the newest fashion line
from kids super so this thing came out
of nowhere right
get invited to go to France
um and you know I don't like the French
you know it
if you had to pick six things I don't
like the French would be four of them
and uh so I got invited they were doing
a comedy fashion show this fella kids
super and at first they said kid super I
thought it was one of you know like a
Make-a-Wish fellas you know you simply
get those you know they got that 40 year
old in a cape or something and he's
you know he wants to jump out of a wind
or whatever and they won't let him
because he's
you know does he never because he's
you know he's mentally he's really you
know because the devil tickled him
whenever he was being made or whatever
and he's not well
but it wasn't so last week was Men's
Fashion Week in Paris which is an event
held every year that's basically just
like the Super Bowl for Rich
metrosexuals and usually has nothing to
do with comedy that all changed on
Sunday though when designer kid super
put on a fashion show full of comedians
who walked down the runway modeling his
new designs and then performed stand-up
comedy jokes lightly roasting the
clothes his own show the kids Super Show
where he basically has a bunch of comics
wearing the clothes it's not the
traditional models you know there are
santinos out there Stavros is out there
Theo Vaughn was out there Jeff Ross
Mateo yeah Yvonne Yvonne yeah she was
great and uh he's a Frenchman he's a
French comedian exactly and then yo Jay
Balvin came and did a joke like amazing
yeah yeah and then Tyra hosts it oh [__]
yeah yeah I knew Tara was there and uh
and then I was on the show obviously as
well and then like like doing that and
like transforming what one of these
fashion shows can be like it was by far
the just the most unique way of
delivering the show yeah and basically
when you look at all these other
fashions shows you're basically trying
to go what's the obstacle course for
these emaciated people to walk around it
yeah that's the that's the challenge
it's like do they walk around in nothing
do they walk around on water do they
walk around in a house like what is it
and he was just like nah we're not doing
it with models we're going to have these
comedians go up there including comics
and Fashion Week to show off your new
designs is already a sick idea but when
you really think about it take it one
step farther the audience that got to
see these guys all on one show
performing live stand up that's absurd
for them what a show theovan Andrew
Schultz Andrew Santino Stavros Jeff Ross
if all these guys came together and
announced European tour together the
demand for those tickets would be
instantly through the roof they'd
probably end up playing Arenas or at
least huge theaters the theater held
like 1300 which you didn't know I didn't
know I thought it was gonna be 50 people
yeah that's what I would have thought me
too so I was just like yeah I'm just
gonna make fun of this [__] in
front of his friends and like these high
fashion people and then whatever and I
found out the night before it's in this
beautiful [__] theater I was like oh
I gotta like write some jokes to this
[__] like this is this is going to be a
real thing that I got to succeed
we go outside of the [__] show before
it starts there's 5 000 people that are
trying to get into the venue oh the
police are called it's barricaded
there's fist fights in the street like
fashion fist Fighters which is hilarious
right like dudes with nails and [__]
scratching each other like it is crazy
okay they got a barricade the venue so
people don't go in they have to bring
down those metal things like their
clothes yeah and the baby was like we're
not doing this [__] today the venue's
like we can't hold this many people the
fire department is getting called [__]
they thought a show would get canceled
for a second because it was just so bad
and then you have to think like best
case scenario yes yes definitely no one
gets hurt but yeah yes for sure but
remember the people that you want in
that show are the writers from Vogue and
and from woman's War daily and buyers
for all these places because you want
our boy to get the you know get the
press and get this and they're coming
from another show all over so they're
showing up and it's 5 000 people outside
most possible thing that could ever
happen
before this show even started I was like
Mark it would be awesome if we all went
up and killed do you know it would be
better
if this show never [__] happened yeah
because 5 000 people tried to break into
it and it was just absolute Mayhem it's
like well what is it why why is there so
much energy around kiss super as far as
the actual performances go each comedian
was instructed to walk out on stage like
a model and then perform a few minutes
of stand-up lightly roasting fashion or
the fashion industry obviously a lot of
people in the crowd are in the fashion
industry and not every comedian had
clothing related jokes already worked
out and ready to go so there's
definitely some pressure on these guys
to rise to the occasion which it sounds
like they did this was the most nervous
that I'd been
to do common in a long time because for
one people are coming to ju they judge
clothing I mean this is like fancy
people this is like the fanciest people
everybody has a Blog everybody has a web
page everybody has a lawyer it's people
like that and so you get it's like I
knew these people were going to be are
judgmental about clothes anyway they're
gonna they're they're here to judge
clothing all week
so if you throw in an outlier like a
comedian who's coming in who's not even
part of their world
we're the easiest thing for them to hate
on oh I can hate on this guy oh easy
done comedian done
so I feel I was like oh these are my
first man and it was rich people bro
and I don't like the rich man
I've said it and you know it the crazy
thing was not knowing what the audience
was I was like did these [__]
speak English are they
kids super specific fans are they
fashion fans like because I wanted to
make some jokes about fashion because
when will I ever have the opportunity to
do that like kind of specific nuanced
[__] yeah so but a too cool show
typically is not good typically but
that's why it was the frenzy people got
in I think they're already more geeked
so it's a hotter crowd and they're more
willing to laugh because like I'm gonna
enjoy this [__] that much more because
they couldn't get in and I could
personally I wanted to hear what comedy
fans thought of these Fashion Week
cameos so I put up this poll on our
second Channel clip World asking people
to decide who had the best fit between
Stavros Theo Von Andrew Santino and
Andrew Schultz the results were not even
close theovan wanted a landslide with 56
of the vote followed by Stavros with 24
Andrew Santina with 13 of the vote and
coming in last was Andrew Schultz with
just seven percent I don't know much
about fashion you know that I mean look
at me
there you go and you know I don't you
know I got three pairs of pants I wear
one of them all the time this is it
these little camo deals there's paper
thin but they're nice from North Face
and I like them
um
but anyway we get invited to this thing
and they said it's gonna be I mean
you're wearing I mean some of the land
and this is just damn fresh silk I mean
if you could smell a spider's ass hole
on it at the end of the day it seems
like this event was a huge success for
everyone involved whenever comedians can
be celebrated in a mainstream light like
this I feel like it's good for comedy in
general these guys all got a nice
write-up about them in Vogue got to
travel to Paris for free and got to
party with Kodak Black afterwards which
is pretty sweet
come on
that does it for this video as always
thank you so much for watching and we'll
be back again Monday with some more
comedy news if you didn't get a chance
to vote on the clip World Poll comment
on this video who you think had the best
Fashion Week fit I personally still
think it was Theo also shout out to Ted
for this new sign
[Music]